hey everybody it's mike from order flows
and today i'm going to be talking about
understanding you know big orders
trading in the order flow you know one
of the benefits of using an order flow
footprint chart is to see when size
comes into the market and how it
actually trades as opposed to say
looking at you know the the dome or
a heat map or book map where you're just
seeing the liquidity coming
in and sitting there in the market i'm
talking about what actually trades now
a few things you have to keep in mind
each market trades different volumes
okay so what's considered big volume in
one market might be considered average
or small in another market you know so
for example say you are trading e-minis
you know which trades a lot of volume um
you know what's considered
small in
the e-minis would be considered big in
say
um
gold or the euro currencies
so you got to take the time to learn
what's considered big volume or above
average volume for the market that
you're trading now
how do you do that well you look at the
footprint chart and again it's not like
you have to analyze you know five years
worth of data you know really what
you're looking for is how the market is
trading now how the volume is going
through and if you're starting to see
increases in the volume so for example
this is today in the gold and
you know this time it's about 11
30 going into lunchtime and you can see
how the volume is you know more or less
pretty light okay you're seeing some
small size you know nine uh six two you
know sort of the bigger volume that's
being traded on the bid or the offer
here you got 30 29 38 you know 20 20 34
17 16. um here's 64.46 so you know i'd
guess
anything over 30 would you know
something that would catch my interest
in the market now when you're seeing big
volume coming into the market
you want to take
into account where it's coming in
right now if a market is selling off
it's not uncommon to see
big volumes on the bid side right
because you know people are
working bids you know in anticipation of
buying the market lower okay just as
you know if the market was rallying up
you'd probably see some big offers
coming in because people are trying to
uh take profits at higher prices now
where it gets interesting
is you know when you sort of come down
into a low like
right in here okay markets sold off
again i don't say sold off but you know
it dropped from
was about 1945 down to 1943 pretty quick
you know a two dollar move down and then
you know we're seeing
some bids in here right 47 lots traded
on the bid right in here at 1944. you
know and this was just below this sort
of swing low you know people are they're
trying to buy the market have been going
sideways right for the last um you know
20 30 minutes and so it's not uncommon
to see people you know putting in bids
you know just below the
you know the swing low
and they probably had some offers up
here at uh 19 45 60 or
1945 70. so here you got 47 okay market
trades down through that comes down it's
a couple more bids down here some decent
size 24 27
then the market starts creeping back up
starts creeping back up into this area
that you had just been trading at okay
around the 1944
50 1944 60 70 80 up to about 1945.
however on this way up
now first let's talk before we talk
about the way up let's talk about the
way down so we get through some size
here right there's 50 on the bid here
47.
and as we're going down you're seeing
some not a lot of offers coming in
trailing it down okay so what that's
telling you is somebody's coming in here
and cleaning out these bids right
there's probably a big order that's
coming through it trades out the 47 lots
you know the 17 trades everything out
because there's very little counter
trade here so they're just coming in
hitting the bids hitting the bids
hitting the bids gets down here 19
43 30
okay you see there's 38 that traded on
the offer there so as we're coming down
right
now you're starting to see the offer
come in trailing it down okay which is a
sign of supply coming into the market
now it gets through you know the 24 at
320 the 27 at 310
and you know trades all the way down to
270 okay now it starts to come back up
but there's still a decent size offer at
42.90 here so you had a decent offer
here at 43.30 another decent offer at
42.90 so there is
some supply
coming in trailing the off trailing the
you know the move down right basically
um there's pressure on the market
you have sellers coming in working
offers on the way down however now now
it starts trading up so we go through
that 39
that we're offered there right trades
the 39 there turns bid for 15. um 18 get
lifted at 43 14 get lifted at 43.10
um thin volume up here you know just
very small size but when it gets into
this bar here it's 32 you know it's bid
for 32 well it's probably bid for more
but 32 trade so there's some absorption
now you're starting to see up on the way
back up
as opposed to just
offers getting lifted so now right as
the market was moving down you have
offers trailing the move down now on the
move up you're starting to see some
support of buying right the 32
the 33 the 37 the 23.
so
on this way down you're seeing what you
expect to see on on a move down
it did hit its inflection point right
down here at around 43 okay
then the buyers started coming in right
the buyers came in they aggressively
lifted this offer here at um 290.
right bought it up they're bidding it
here at 43.40 bidding again you know at
360 at 370 at 390. 4410
4420 right so
after you see what's happening in these
three bars
okay
what should be thinking well this market
probably gonna go higher and it moves
back all the way up back up to 460. now
you know then it just sort of went
sideways and sort of dipped back down
but this area where you start seeing
this you know this aggressive buying
um coming in followed by passive buying
right in here you know we'll call it
this area
right in here because this is where the
the interesting size that came in and
again
in the e-minis
if you're looking at you know 39 32 37
33 that wouldn't be considered big size
for that market but for the gold at this
time of day that's considered big size
again it's all relative to the market
that you're trading
so basically this area where you had
buying interest come in here okay
you had
some aggressive lifting of the offers
then you had some nice passive bids
following it up you know
one of the clues of
what can be happening is in the delta
right you've seen the negative delta
people say how can this market go up on
negative delta right because
theoretically
you would be expecting a bar with
negative delta to be going down right
because what is delta well delta is
you know the net difference of
aggressive buying and aggressive selling
so if you have negative delta that tells
you there was more aggressive selling
than aggressive buying and generally
what's going to help move the market is
the aggressive
in this case would be the aggressive
buying on a move up people are buying
the offer taking out the liquidity from
the offer and buy the next offer then
buy the next offer they're clearing it
out but what's causing this negative
delta is
absorption
so you have bidders coming in here
passive buyers coming in working bids
they're absorbing all the selling that's
going on
right then the selling stops and
aggressive buying takes over then they
start working some more bids they absorb
all the aggressive selling the
aggressive selling
tapers off and aggressive buying comes
in and goes higher but there's just more
aggressive selling than aggressive
buying it's not taking much on the
aggressive buying to move the market
higher so you're basically looking at a
level between you know 42 90 and 44 20.
you see how the market went up came
right back down to that 4420 area right
here this blue line
and you know went back up so it's acting
as essentially a support area because
you know at that area you had buying
interest right legitimate buying
interest and
if you're just looking at the market
right and you're wondering oh why does
the market come back to this level well
that's one of the reasons why markets
pull back to a certain level and then
continue on in their original direction
is because it finds levels like that
where there was buying earlier okay so
let's take a look at euro currency now
again like i said just to reiterate you
know under your volume is relative to
the market that you're trading so you
know right now
i have this chart open it's about nine
o'clock in the morning and you can see
the volumes that are going through um
you know nothing really stands out above
100 you know here's 254 but everything
else is relatively
on the smaller side you know 60 52 49 a
lot of 40s you know here's 80 here's 91.
so you know anything obviously above 100
which should get my interest obviously
the 254 um
you know kind of gets my interest but
then there's not much
really else to go on afterwards that
happened to it did the market go up a
little bit yeah um it came
in this 254 came in at what is that
108.68
and you know the market did start to
rally a bit but again
just having one bar with you know a big
order in there that trades through is
you know
not always enough to go off of so you
know just wait for something that makes
more sense and as we get up here right
we rally you know this red line is the
low of the day
so we rally up from uh 108.63
and then we get up into this area uh you
know around 108.80 and we start going
sideways and what was interesting in
here you're starting to see some decent
offers get lifted right here is 156
here's 158 here's 163 okay so again like
i said earlier it's not uncommon to see
resting liquidity
in the offers
especially when the market is going up
right because people that bought earlier
um
you know probably want to get out at
higher prices so to see the market sort
of come up here and you know trade that
out trade it out up here
is not uncommon now where it gets
interesting
is this here this 152 so
before right we had the market went up
from 63 all the way up to you know
basically 83 a 20 tick rally
and you know people that bought earlier
they're getting out up here but now what
you're seeing is
supportive buying coming in here right
you're seeing this
bid come in here at 152. right it's not
coming in on the offer side it's coming
in on the bid so now there's support
coming into this market market is
starting to go higher now you're seeing
support come into the market
so what do you think is going to happen
well the one the support can hold the
market go higher too the support can
fail
and market can drop now
again you know sometimes especially with
euro currency
um you know there's a lot of trade that
goes on between you know a lot of our
trade that goes on between the cash in
the futures but you gotta you know when
you're invested in the market and you
know you're trading you you want to sort
of put the pieces together okay so i
know i've got a big bid that came in
here now this is an area that we had
been trading in basically for since
about nine you know 9 24 9 25 it's 9 40.
so about
15 minutes
all of a sudden you're seeing a big bid
come in the market okay
all you got to do right you just wait
for the market to give you some sort of
confirmation that you know this market
is you know this could be supportive for
the market because if it's going to be
supportive for the market we shouldn't
dip you know much below the above the uh
sorry below that 1080 level and it just
goes two ticks lower down to 79. you
know it didn't come down here all you
know didn't pull back down to you know
76 or 75 and then you're seeing some
more in the next bar what are you seeing
you're seeing selling imbalances on this
green candle
right
20 against four 43 against nine
so not only do you have that supportive
buying in this bar
in the next bar
it's still there it's come back right
even though you know this order got
filled it traded a little bit lower
next bar
it's still there even at the next price
it's still there
so
then this bar closes you know you could
feel fairly confident that yeah you know
what i think you know there's probably
some move to the upside here
because i now i know i've got support of
buying right so this old business of
this move up which was sort of closed
when you know people were getting out of
their positions here now you're seeing
new business come into the market right
new supportive buying coming into the
market and what the market do well the
market went up from this 80 well this is
80 right but you know maybe you're
getting in around 84.85 well you know
all the way up to you know above uh
109 even
right
so
you know that's where understanding how
the big size comes into the market what
effect it's going to have on the market
again you know trading is a puzzle you
got to put the pieces of the puzzle
together so you can understand what's
going on it's just not about seeing the
big size it's seeing where the big size
came in in relationship to how the
market is trading
so if you like this video and you want
to see more like it be sure to hit the
like button and subscribe to my channel
and i hope to be put out more videos
like this i hope you found this helpful
if you did hit the like button bye bye
everyone